i like that right there and let me let
me ask you this one real quick snoop
because sean payton was not on the
sideline tonight for new orleans what do
you think he was thinking sitting on the
couch watching this game play out uh
chasing hill please just hold on to the
ball
take a knee
the clock milk it milk it milk it
and for me
we got a little sean payton tweet i'm
told right after they always got that
account active look how many answers is
on there yes
you got more answers than snoop dogg
he's happy he's got a great defensive
line because them boys they were
athletic they were physical and they got
after tom brady i have not seen tom fole
since probably about 2007 when they uh
when the giants beat us yeah and michael
strahan and all those boys was coming
after tom but this was a heck of a
performance that's a tribute to coach
you know rod if you really wanna you
know the players did they think but if
your coach your head coach is not here
and you play that way
you've been coached up no question no
question sean payton's one of the best
coaches in the nfl we never doubted that
we just heard snoop mention taysom hill
what did you see from tayson hill out
here tonight
you know what i doubt it if he could
throw the ball down the field he threw
the ball down the field for a couple big
plays and i was actually proud of him
you know i mean i don't think tayson
hill is going to be a great quarterback
you know by any stretch of the means
he's going to be one of these
serviceable quarterbacks but at the end
of the day he came in he did he made
enough plays with his legs with his arms
and i thought he handled the situation
big he beat tom brady at home in his own
backyard pretty impressive well you say
we include snoop on a little damn okay
right here what do you think about that
right yeah i like it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports